if you think we need animal protein to
thrive think again
gone are the days of strict dietary
requirements we live in the age of
nutritional choices based on a person's
biochemical individuality in other words
choose the foods that work best for your
body today on million ways to live we
spend the day with a rich role one of
the fittest men on the planet who went
against all mainstream marketing and
hype and shut his critics up by
listening to the innate wisdom of his
own body
through trial and error rich learned
that the optimal fuel for his mind and
body was one based on vegan principles
since then he has conquered the ultraman
challenge a grueling three-day 320 mile
endurance race and followed it up with
the epic five challenge completing five
Ironman triathlons on five different
Hawaiian Islands in less than a week my
journey towards eating plant-based was
kind of an easy decision because at the
time my wife was already vegetarian I
knew she was healthy and I wasn't so it
was an easy decision to jump on the
Household bandwagon first thing I did
was a juice fast which was cruelly and
brutal and painful it was very much like
coming off drugs and at the time I
didn't think that my junk food habit was
an addiction until I felt those
withdrawal symptoms but once the fog
cleared I knew I was never going back to
my old way of life because I'd never
experienced such levels of clarity and
energy and focus before and the next
question of course is what are you gonna
eat now I decided to adopt a vegetarian
diet but I quickly realized that just
because I was vegetarian that that did
not necessarily mean that I was healthy
there are plenty of unhealthy vegetarian
and vegan junk foods out there and
believe me I ate all of them thinking I
was healthy french fries potato chips
vegan cupcakes pancakes even Oreos are
technically vegan after about six months
of being a junk food vegetarian I had
played it out I was back on the couch I
hadn't lost any weight my energy levels
had plummeted again and I thought what
would happen if I got rid of all the
processed foods what would happen if I
got rid of all the dairy products what
would happen if I went 100% entirely a
food plant-based once I started looking
past the labels and choosing high
quality nutrient-dense superfoods like
quinoa and avocados started embracing a
diet rich in fruits and vegetables my
energy levels were stored and I felt
like I did in the latter days of that
juice cleanse
I was so energized I had to go outside
and start exercising again even though
the triathlon is an individual event
rich knows that a supporting cast is the
most important part of any successful
venture
for rich there's no one more important
to his team than his wife Julie my
greatest enemy has always been me left
to my own devices I will generally
self-sabotage any effort towards getting
healthy but I'm lucky enough to be
married to Julie and Julie has always
been my rock she provides me
unconditional love and support and she's
also been an amazing teacher introducing
me to things like meditation yoga things
that are rejuvenating my body after
intense training days life is about
balance everything Julie is and stands
for represents that balance for me good
things don't come easy starting at
Ground Zero rich pushed his body to
levels only few humans have ever
experienced milestones like that don't
just happen overnight
trying to find efficiencies and ways to
streamline your life is fine there's
nothing wrong with that but I do have a
problem when the hacking the life
hacking the bio hacking becomes the
destination rather than a tool hacks may
trick the human mind into thinking
something has been accomplished but you
can't trick the body your body is
constantly adapting to the environment
you place it in and a quick hack simply
is not going to offset years of bad
habits rather than focusing on shortcuts
and hacks do the internal work to find
out what makes your heart beat parties
when you find your purpose and calling
follow it with all of your heart and
soul I've got to stick with it and if
you do you'll find that your journey
will be the most amazing adventure you
can possibly imagine